before there was this guy there was this
guy a rich flamboyant media Titan who
wanted nothing more than to be President
of the United States
he was basically Donald Trump before
Donald Trump Bernard McFadden born
August 16th 1868 later changed his name
to burn our because he thought it made
him sound more like a lion's roar made
his money in publishing and became known
as one of the godfathers of the tabloid
so naturally he plastered his face all
over his magazines but Bernards real
passion was fitness he fashioned himself
a personal trainer and spawned a
religion Cosmo Terry anism which blended
his wacky health theories with the Bible
he was married four times one wife was
26 years his junior
another nearly 40 but things really get
interesting when Bernard gets into
politics he started by campaigning for
the creation of a new position named the
Secretary of Health Bernard didn't get
the job
so he aimed higher in 1936 he ran for
president boasting that all illegal and
poor immigrants should be shipped back
to their homelands sound familiar
he didn't get the Republican nomination
so he tried again this time he ran as a
Democrat in Florida for a seat in the US
Senate
he didn't win then he ran for mayor of
New York City but he wasn't even allowed
on the ballot though he never won any
election and eventually ran out of money
his quest for fame never died for his
84th birthday he parachuted out of an
airplane in Paris
[Music]
[Music]